[Music]
you are walking : TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
to go go here burlier decade-old Tesla
is already gigantic and adored Morgan
Stanley calls it the world's most
important car company and a 2014
American nationwide survey found that
Tesla's Model S was the most loved
vehicle in America other seasoned
manufacturers such as BMW and
mercedes-benz are now getting involved
in the fully electric movement even
Apple is said to have an electric car in
the works so how did this all happen in
this video we'll find out exactly how
Tesla began learn some amazing facts
about the company and then we'll see
just how big it is compared to other
traditional car companies you may just
learn a thing or two so let's get
straight into it
contrary to popular belief many of the
first cars in the late 1800s were
actually electric vehicles well the
first electric cars were actually
carriages with electric motors because
electricity had started to come in in
the 1890s we do have a photograph a lot
number of those cars in front of
Delaware Park Casino in nineteen two as
we move forward it was discovered that
incredible amounts of money could be
made by selling petrol and electric cars
faded by the wayside interesting it's
hard to beat an electric car the problem
with electric cars is there isn't a
single practical reasonably priced new
electric vehicle on the US market right
now ten years ago Detroit seemed
positively plugged in here
he's here General Motors built at least
about a thousand of the fabled eveyone's
after a California law mandated sales of
zero-emission vehicles I think it's the
future I'm happy but by 2003 California
backed out GM repo'd the eveyone's
and destroyed them amid protests they
are fearful of how disruptive plug-in
cars will be and how unattractive their
old product line will appear over the
years the electric car never really saw
much hope but in July 2003 a
world-changing event happened in the CR
Tesla Motors was founded by Martin ever
hand and Mark to penning the very next
year
Elon Musk invested heavily into the
company and joined Tesla's Board of
Directors as its chairman from the
beginning must consistently had a vision
he wanted Tesla to be something special
its long-term goal was to create
affordable mass-market electric vehicles
for everyone musk oversaw the detailed
product design of the company's first
car the Tesla Roadster he oversaw
components ranging from the power
electronics to the headlamps and other
styling eelain's design was so good that
he received the global green 2006
product design award for his work on the
road stop the Roadster was the first
production electric vehicle with a range
over 200 miles of 320 kilometers on a
single charge
in 2007 Tesla went from strength to
strength and received investment from
prominent entrepreneurs including
Google's co founders Larry Page and
Sergey Brin however in 2008 the fallout
from the world's first ever global
financial crisis forced Tesla to cut
their workforce by 10% this included key
personnel who had been involved from the
very inception
freaked-out waiting to see how low down
will go in late 2008 after being on
Tesla's board of directors Elon Musk
became the CEO and he contributed
seventy million dollars of his own money
into the company he really believed in
his vision for the electric car in 2009
Tesla received a loan from the US
government which support of the
engineering and production of the Model
S sedan interestingly enough by 2013
Tesla had fully repaid the government
while Ford and Nissen who had received a
similar loan hadn't Tesla unveiled the
Model S all-electric sedan on March the
26th 2009 and by August 2009 the company
had finally become profitable in 2010
Tesla went public it was the first
American car maker to go public since
the Ford Motor Company in 1956 Tesla
success is just that more amazing
because of the public's resistance to
electric cars previously electric cars
were seen as quirky strange devices and
almost never taken seriously to prove
themselves they just had to be better
than a traditional car in every single
way so no logical haters could even
exist well ok you might be asking how
exactly is Tesla better well it's not a
hybrid which means that the only liquid
that needs topping up is the wiper fluid
there's no noise or vibration it's much
cleaner it has instant torque and
acceleration which means it's extremely
fast it handles much better than your
average car and even better than most
sports cars due to extremely low center
of gravity and this is because of its
unique battery weight distribution and
finally it's also much much safer than
the standard car ok so what do I mean by
safe well I guess this is a good time to
move on to some facts about Tesla
[Music]
Tesla cars are incredibly safe Tesla's
Model S received a five-star rating in
every possible category something which
has only been achieved by 1% of cars and
the Model S has set a new record for the
lowest likelihood of passenger injury in
the testing of the Model S it was so
strong that it broke the test rig so why
is it so safe well because there's no
engine at the front of the car the whole
front behaves like a massive crumple
zone absorbing a lot more impact in the
crash so what about the batteries in an
accident when the batteries just blow up
and catch fire nope this isn't true the
average petrol car is actually 500
percent more likely to blow up in a
serious accident and that's mainly
because it's a petrol bomb on wheels all
right so that all sounds pretty good but
I want some actual proof it's hard to
imagine anyone surviving this crash but
it appears to be further testament to
Tesla's safety claims a stolen Tesla
split in half after crashing into a pole
during a high-speed police chase in West
Hollywood Friday you can see the back
end of the car ended up between the
walls of a nearby synagogue several
people were hurt but amazingly no one
was killed
ok so that's kind of interesting but
what other cool facts are there if
you're in the United States Tesla has
plans for you to travel anywhere for
free this is something that allows you
to make a brief stop at one of our Tesla
supercharger stations a charge a call
very quickly and be on your way
something that's unique about the
supercharger is that it's free it's not
just free now it's free forever the
number of Tesla super charging stations
is increasing dramatically
a year from now we'll have covered 80
percent of the North American population
and within two years over ninety eight
percent so by buying a Tesla you
essentially have free long-distance
travel throughout the country forever
I think the reasoning behind this is so
that Tesla can create a new better
cleaner infrastructure and then when
electric cars become more widespread
Tesla could begin to generate some
income by letting other companies use
the system while keeping it free for the
end-users this is pure genius
on a single charge it's possible to go
from Boston to New York with 60 miles of
range left Tesla cars are really really
fast the Tesla Model S can do 0 to 60
miles an hour or roughly 0 to 100
kilometers an hour in 3.2 seconds
Nestor's fast as a McLaren at Spyder
Elon Musk almost sold Tesla to Google in
March of 2013
Elon Musk was having a terrible time
Tesla was almost bankrupt SpaceX wasn't
working out and many people just weren't
buying electric cars because of this
Elon Musk was actually about to sell the
company to Google for 11 billion dollars
but fortunately later that year things
worked out and the rest was history
Tesla wants to power your home Elon Musk
recently Justin vowed his latest branch
of Tesla Tesla energy Tesla energy plans
to reduce the energy costs of the
average household by running houses off
a specially designed battery product
called the power wall if you want to
know more please check out my previous
video and it goes into more detail about
the power wall and what it means for
society it'll be the first link in the
description below ok so what are some
other interesting things about Tesla
Tesla always gives out a lot of its
patents for free to encourage
competition Tesla is also planning to
release the Tesla 3 which realizes Elon
Musk's original dream the Tesla for the
common man is costing just thirty five
thousand dollars before incentives in an
odd twist the watermelon sized motor
that powers Tesla's vehicles it's based
off an AC motor a core technology which
was patented by none other than Nikola
Tesla in 1888
another interesting fact auto-pilot
Tesla Model S's have already been in
production since late 2014 the latest
models include cameras and a set of
sonars that give a 360-degree buffer
around the car the car can detect road
signs lane markings obstacles and other
vehicles these features are going to be
activated in the future by over-the-air
software updates which i think is a very
interesting
way of doing things for a vehicle so
let's finally put things into a bit of
perspective here just how big is Tesla
compared to other car manufacturers out
there well as you might have guessed
Tesla isn't the largest water
manufacturer around they just haven't
been around for long enough and of
course the automotive industry is one of
the toughest to break into so really
that doesn't make any sense that being
said though Tesla is probably a little
bit bigger than you think currently
they're really worth more than fiat
Mitsubishi Motors Mazda Renault or
Suzuki with a market cap of 31 billion
dollars it's almost half as big as Ford
Motor Company keep in mind that those
traditional companies have been around
for a long time so here's a question how
many cars has Tesla sold so far about
70,000 General Motors sells that many in
three days however take a look at this
General Motors market cap is 56 billion
dollars and I said earlier Tesla's is
already 31 billion dollars so it just
goes to show that Tesla is vastly more
valued in investors eius than
traditional companies and remember this
is all excluding Tesla energy also in
regards to sales consider this Tesla
cars are usually sold in shopping malls
not dealerships in fact many dealership
associations have actually tried to file
lawsuits to ban the direct sale of Tesla
cars incredibly Tesla sales are banned
in the state of Texas is it a
coincidence that Texas is also the home
of big oil either side I have no comment
the company has 10,000 employees and
made 3.2 billion dollars in revenue in
2014 although that number is absolutely
dwarfed by the bigger companies out
there it's not bad for just over a
decade okay so what does this tell us
while stepping aside that most of the
financial system is in the bubble right
now so stocks throw a bit overvalued
Tesla's still does show that a good idea
and simply doing things better can still
work in today's fast-moving world the
automotive industry has been doing
basically the same thing for a hundred
years
namely putting flammable liquid in
confined metal cylinders blowing it up
by either flame or pressure and
generating power from
and then Tesla comes along breaks into
the market and smashes the old norms to
pieces the fact that Tesla is a
brand-new smaller company and still
manages to cause so much change and
instigate a fundamental disruption to
the automotive industry is a testament
to the innovation of the company so is
Tesla the future at this point it
actually kind of seems so I mean another
company could come out of the blue and
do it better than Tesla has but so far
with innovations such as the
supercharger charging station and
superior car design Tesla are well on
the way to creating a vibrant fully
electric car industry and the
accompanying infrastructure to change
the world so in the wider and deeper
sense of things
Elon Musk had a vision a vision for
everyone to own a great electric car in
2013 his vision almost slipped through
his fingers but he held on to it and
today is well on the path to achieving
that very vision so really if you've got
a goal in front of you always keep
striving to achieve it the ROK's to be a
bit windy but you'll get there in the
end this has been to gogo and I want to
thank you for watching this cold fusion
video cheers guys and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video
[Music]
hey guys thanks for watching the whole
way through the video hopefully you
learned something from it and you really
enjoyed that story cuz you know really
the story of Tesla is one of those
stories that is really cool it's just
you know for a lack of a better word
because it's a company that's only 10
years old and yet they came along and
actually fundamentally changed the way
industry thinks about cars or consumers
think about cars I should say and you
know to have something that's been so
successful in such a short amount of
time is really just a testament to real
innovation so you know it's one of the
stories that I really enjoyed
researching and hopefully you got
something out of that and you learn
something new and if you did yeah please
feel free to share this video I mean
it's just a great story and it's a
really encouraging anecdote that just
one person along with a great team of
course can actually fundamentally change
the world ok so I think that's enough
from me so give it a thumbs up if you
liked it share with a friend who you
think would be interested and I'll catch
you again soon for the next video cheers
guys
cold fusion its me thinking
you